kampf gegen steigende ansteckungszahlen
die große mehrheit der deutschen steht
hinter den maßnahmen der bundesregierung
konsequenz aus plagiats-affäre
bundesfamilienministerin franziska
giffey verzichtet auf ihren doktortitel
und kein hinweis auf wahlbetrug die
zuständigen us behörden weisen gemeinsam
und offiziell die vorwürfe von präsident
amt zurück
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann beim ski
wunder familie schon lange vor corona
war klar was jetzt erst recht ans licht
kommt fast überall fehlen pflegekräfte
um das zu ändern schloss sich vor zwei
jahren die beteiligten ministerien
verbände und krankenkassen zur
konzertierten aktion pflege zusammen
heute ihre erste bilanz und sei noch
nicht am ziel aber auf dem weg dahin zu
mehr stellen einer besseren bezahlung
und einer guten ausbildung andrea maurer
es ist ein harter job den pflegekräfte
täglich leisten noch mal härter wird er
durch die bedingungen unter denen sie
ihn ausüben müssen geringes gehalt
massiver personalmangel konzertierte
aktion pflege nennen die minister sparen
giffey und teil das projekt dass sie
2018 gestartet haben
die zwischenbilanz fällt mitten in die
panini diese pandemie hat in der pflege
eine schwierige oft unzureichende lage
noch weiter verstärkt sie ist quasi ein
problem beschleuniger mehr personal mehr
ausbildung mehr geld mehr digitales das
haben sie sich zum auftrag gemacht
13.000 zusätzliche vollzeitstellen
wurden etwa in der altenpflege
geschaffen aber nur 3600 stellen konnten
bislang besetzt werden
arbeitsmarkt ist leergefegt das eine ist
es die stellen zu finanzieren und zu
schaffen das andere ist es sie auch
tatsächlich besetzen zu können
doch die minister zeigen sich auch
zufrieden mit dem bisher erreichten eine
ausbildungsoffensive mehr urlaubstage
für pflegekräfte und ein einheitlicher
mindestlohn für ost und west
bis erste april 2022 wird er für
pflegehilfskräfte stufenweise auf 12 eur
55 angehoben und ab ersten juli 2021
steigt er für pflegefachkräfte auf 15
euro ein flächendeckender tarifvertrag
soll folgen geht es nach dem
arbeitsminister schon in wenigen wochen
ich kann hier und heute deutlich sagen
sobald mir dieser antrag auf
vollstreckung eines solchen
tarifvertrages vorliegt werden wir ihn
zügig prüfen und wenn die voraussetzung
des gesetzes erfüllt sind
einen tarifvertrag für die gesamte
branche für allgemeinverbindlich
erklären
der arbeitsminister nennt das riesen
chance doch der gesundheitsminister
bremst offen sei wer die mehrkosten
trage die pandemie mark problem
beschleuniger sein ob sie die lösungen
der probleme beschleunigt wird sich
zeigen müssen
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen da gibt es in deutschland einen
neuen höchstwert das robert koch
institut meldet 23542 neue infektionen
so viele wie noch nie binnen 24 stunden
der blick auf den schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage zeigt aber auch
dass die zahlen zuletzt weniger stark
zugenommen haben es bestätigt sich die
kurve flacht ab weil mittlerweile labore
an ihre grenzen stoßen empfiehlt das
robert koch institut eine neue strategie
nicht mehr alle menschen mit husten
schnupfen oder halsweh zu testen sondern
wer solche symptome hat soll erst mal zu
hause bleiben wenn es schlimmer wird
dann bitte zum test bei atemnot fieber
oder störung von geruchs und
geschmackssinn unbedingt sofort testen
lassen
die ersten bundesländer setzten die neue
strategie jetzt um darunter das saarland
susanne freitag
es ist weniger los als sonst tag eins
der neuen test strategie in saarbrücken
das robert-koch-institut hat sie
empfohlen die labore müssen entlastet
werden weil im winter auch andere
krankheitserreger zu chur wird ähnlichen
symptomen führen können soll es klare
prioritäten
eigentlich eine reduktion wenn man so
will auch wirklich ernsthaft
symptomatischen patienten also klien ich
wirklich relevant erkrankte und auf
andere gruppen die wirklich einen
kontakt haben wo es ein app ideologisch
zusammenhang zu einem schon bekannten
mit 19 von ihnen gibt ausnahme bayern
während alle bundesländer die neuen
regeln umgesetzt haben oder noch
umsetzen werden soll es hier weiter
flächendeckend kostenlose tests für alle
geben bei uns ist es eben wichtig dass
auch jemand ja nur leichte symptome hat
einen test bekommen kann um für sich
selber und sein umfeld sicherheit zu
haben und dass wir dann auch schnell die
infect ketten unterbrechen können teile
der ärzteschaft und ein labor verband
kritisierten den bayerischen sonderweg
sie warnen vor überlastung die
neuinfektionen auf rekordniveau ob die
korona beschränkungen verlängert werden
müssen wird am montag thema sein
bei der konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
für die bundesregierung kann ich sagen
dass bei diesem stand der dinge für
montag jedenfalls keine lockerungen von
einschränkungen zu erwarten sind die
kann es noch nicht geben
unser ziel bleibt es uns wieder dem
incidents wert von 50 anzunähern
immerhin der anstieg der
infektionszahlen flacht langsam ab grund
für eine entwarnung ist das aber noch
lange nicht fast zwei der mindestens
vier wochen mit verschärften kontakt
beschränkungen sind vorbei noch sei es
zu früh um die wirkung zu beurteilen
sagt die bundesregierung aber es ist
nicht zu früh um zu fragen was die
bürger davon halten
dafür ist jetzt matthias fornoff hier im
stall guten abend mit den neuesten
zahlen vom politbarometer matthias auf
welches echo stoßen die strengeren
regeln
na ja im grunde ist das echo sehr
positiv die zustimmung ist sogar
gewachsen
die korona maßnahmen sind gerade richtig
das sagte eine mehrheit von 58 prozent
gut jeder vierte findet sie müssten
sogar noch härter ausfallen und nur 14
prozent halten die einschränkungen für
übertrieben
die krise belastet fast jeden zweiten
auch ganz persönlich trotzdem sind 85
prozent überzeugt dass deutschland in
den nächsten monat
gut durch die pandemie kommt die
aktuellen maßnahmen werden den anstieg
der infektionszahlen begrenzen das
glauben 55 prozent 43 prozent bezweifeln
das
soviel zur krone hochinteressant worte
aber auch die einschätzung wer aus der
union der beste kanzler wäre
hochinteressant und vor allem ziemlich
eindeutig im moment markus söder wäre
als kanzler geeignet das sagt eine
mehrheit von 58 prozent
die eignung aller vier anderen genannten
kandidaten wird mehrheitlich bezweifelt
keine einfache ausgangslage für die cdu
denn alle drei kandidaten für den
parteivorsitz sind derzeit abgeschlagen
gute chancen kanzler zu werden hätte ein
unions kandidat denn wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die union auf
37 prozent minus 1 spd 16 + 1 af den
neuen fdp 5 linke 7 minus 1 die grünen
20 prozent das würde reichen für schwarz
grün und für schwarz-rot weiterhin aber
nicht für grün rot rot vielen dank
matthias komplette zdf politbarometer
mit matthias fornoff gibt es im heute
journal ab 22 uhr alle zahlen finden sie
außerdem in der zdf heute app dort gibt
es im corona blog auch immer alles
aktuelle und viele hintergründe zur
pandemie zum streit um den doktortitel
von familienministerin franziska
gefeiert nachdem die freie universität
berlin doch noch mal neu prüfen will ob
gefahr in ihrer doktorarbeit
abgeschrieben hat zieht die spd
politikerin jetzt die reißleine sie
verzichtet auf den titel
theo koll in berlin was bedeutet das für
die politische karriere der 42 jährigen
nur auf bundesebene soll es
offensichtlich keine auswirkungen haben
das kanzleramt hatte uns am nachmittag
folgendes zitat übermittelt die
bundeskanzlerin hat die erklärung der
ministerin mit respekt zur kenntnis
genommen und freut sich auf die weitere
gute zusammenarbeit das heißt relativ
klar frau gefallen bleibt
bundesfamilienministerin zusätzlich
kandidiert sie aber in zwei wochen
für den vorsitz der berliner spd und so
der plan im kommenden jahr als
spitzenkandidatin für das amt des
regierenden bürgermeisters die ersten
erleichterten reaktionen aus der partei
hier zeigen dass die aktuell sehr
schwache berliner spd aller augen
zudrücken wird den vgh gilt vielen
berliner sozialdemokraten als china
alternativlose hoffnungsträgerin ob nun
mit oder ohne doktor politisch ist das
ganze also eine art flucht nach vorn mit
auf der flucht verloren gegangenem
doktortitel dankeschön nach berlin
pankow europa hat mittlerweile fast so
viele corona fälle wie die usa aktuell
sind laut einer eu behörde zehn
millionen infektionen gemeldet
in den meisten nachbarländern gelten
deutlich strengere einschränkungen als
bei uns viele krankenhäuser sind am
limit und es tauchen probleme auf über
die kaum geredet wird wie an seinem
stern berichtet studenten stehen
schlange uni campus in bordeaux hier
warten sie auf lebensmittelspenden in
der virus krise haben viele ihre
nebenjobs verloren etwa weil bars und
restaurants geschlossen sind meine miete
beträgt 545 euro
wenn ich die bezahlt habe bleiben mehr
aktuell noch 100 euro im monat zum leben
das leben in frankreich bestimmt vom
kampf gegen korona die krankenhäuser
fühlen sich fast 33.000 profit patienten
liegen mittlerweile in den kliniken ein
neuer höchststand
in den letzten tagen kam etwa alle 30
sekunden ein neuer patient in ein
krankenhaus und alle drei minuten eine
auf die intensivstation gefährlich die
lage wieder in italien völlig überfüllt
ein krankenhausflur in neapel
mein vater hatte eine
sauerstoffsättigung von 60 prozent sie
wollten ihn nicht aufnehmen
wir haben sie angefleht erst als sein
zustand noch schlechter wurde haben sie
ihn aufgenommen gestern ist er gestorben
schlimme erinnerungen werden wach an das
frühjahr an ein überfordertes system
helfen sollen drastische maßnahmen
beispiel österreich schon morgen werden
hier die beschränkungen wohl noch einmal
deutlich verschärft fünf jahre nach den
terroranschlägen von paris hat
frankreich der opfer gedacht
regierungschef kast ex und andere
spitzenpolitiker legten an verschiedenen
anschlagszielen kränze nieder
am abend des 13 november hatten
islamisten in der französischen
hauptstadt das konzerthaus peter kloo
angegriffen sowie bars und restaurants
auch das stand de france war ziel eines
anschlags insgesamt kamen 130 menschen
ums leben mehr als 350 wurden verletzt
was können wir gemeinsam tun gegen den
terror gerade auch nach den jüngsten
anschlägen in dresden nizza paris und
wien war das eine der wichtigsten fragen
beim virtuellen treffen der eu
innenminister heute an die gellinek in
brüssel
österreich und frankreich hatten
vorgeschlagen den politischen islam zu
verbieten was ist daraus geworden
ja tatsächlich waren die ersten entwürfe
des abschlusspapiers für die
innenminister die hauptsächlich von
österreich und frankreich verfasst
worden waren sehr viel schärfer
formuliert das was die innenminister
dann heute unter vermittlung der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft angenommen
haben klang dann sehr viel unkonkreter
und sehr viel weichgespülter
innenminister seehofer der den
innenministern den europäischen
innenministern jetzt vorsitzt wies noch
einmal darauf hin dass es nicht darum
gehe religionen wie den islam zu
bekämpfen sondern eben den terror und er
warnte auch davor die themen migration
und terror zu vermischen
ganz konkret haben die innenminister
heute diskutiert wie
die einen zugriff bekommen könnten auf
verschlüsselte messenger dienste auf den
mutmaßliche terroristen sich verabreden
und da wurde klar dass es in europa noch
keine meinung gibt die die
zusammengeführt ist sondern die einen
minister würden am liebsten alles
mitlesen und die anderen innenminister
pochen auf den europäischen datenschutz
fazit der heutigen sitzung es gab viele
starke worte für die europäische
bekämpfung gegen den terror aber wenn es
konkret darum geht das innen mit dass
geheimdienste daten austauschen
dann bleibt europa weiter schwach man
erkennt in die gleiche aus brüssel
vielen dank auch das war thema der
eu-innenminister die reform der
asylpolitik dabei geht es auch um
bessere kontrollen der außengrenzen der
union wie kompromisslos diese grenzen
mitunter schon jetzt verteidigt werden
zeigt sich zb im grenzgebiet des
eu-landes kroatien zum nicht-eu-land
bosnien herzegowina britta hilpert
berichtet aus der umgebung von b liga
klar duscha sie kommen aus dem eu staat
griechenland doch auf der balkanroute
stranden sie im wald von bosnien
herzegowina die lager hier sind voll
manche sicherheitskräfte an der nächsten
ecke grenze mutter die polizei hat alles
genommen und sie hat uns gefoltert geht
zurück nach bosnien riefen sie und haben
uns alle auf den rücken geschlagen
der grenzübertritt ist illegal aber das
rechtfertigt nicht was flüchtlinge der
polizei vorwerfen prügel manchmal sogar
vergewaltigung dann würden sie nach
bosnien zurückgeschickt dort machten
helfer diese fotos zwischen dem 12 21 10
zum beispiel warten uns rund 150
personen und hinten mit verletzungen auf
der ganzen rückseite und den oberarmen
ihnen zufolge stammten die von
sicherheitskräften auf kroatischem
gebiet das kroatische innenministerium
schreibt auf unsere anfrage es habe
begonnen den angeblichen vorfall zu
untersuchen
aber bosnien herzegowina habe keine
geeigneten daten übermittelt
doch seit drei jahren verzeichnen sie in
weniger klar duscher regelmäßig
menschenrechtsverletzungen und nichts
geschehe von organisationen wie die eu
sollten sich darum kümmern um das zu
verhindern meint der arzt muster für
hadzic kroatien erhält von der eu 30
millionen euro zur grenzsicherung ob
dabei auch menschenrechtsverletzungen
geschehen soll nun auf eu ebene
überprüft werden
die weltmacht usa sank weiter erbittert
um den wahlausgang die andere weltmacht
china hat sich nun nach längerem zögern
positioniert und joe biden zum sieg
gratuliert dessen erfolg wird immer
deutlicher sichtbar
mehrere große fernsehsender sind sich
einig dass der demokrat auch in arizona
mit 11.000 stimmen uneinholbar vor
donald trump liegt der präsident zeigt
nach wie vor keine einsicht des trans am
abend ist klar demokrat joe biden
gewinnt auch noch arizona und zementiert
damit seinen sieg über präsident dessen
vorwürfe wegen wahlbetrugs sind derweil
offiziell widerlegt das ministerium für
innere sicherheit und die wahlbehörden
erklären gemeinsam dies sei die
sicherste wahl der amerikanischen
geschichte gewesen
wir haben nun das ministerium für innere
sicherheit das bestätigt nichts von dem
was der präsident sagt ist war es ist
mutig das zu tun
dafür zolle ich ihnen respekt sie tun
das richtige doch trump bleibt bei
seiner linie sieht sich als gewinner und
spricht von wahlbetrug seinem nachfolger
beiden verweigert er weiterhin zugang zu
behördeninformationen und geheimdienst
briefings einige republikaner gehen da
nun nicht mehr mit
im interesse unseres landes sollten der
präsident und sein mitbewerber joe biden
zugang zu geheimdienstberichten bekommen
doch die erste riege der partei steht zu
tom sie sät zweifel am sieg von joe
biden noch ist er nicht präsident
immer es im januar sein wird bekommt die
information unklar wie lange trump und
die republikaner bei dieser linie
bleiben werden die sorge bei manchen ist
groß es ist ein weiterer schritt der
nicht nur die neue beiden regierung
delegitimiert aber auch die demokratie
generell ein gefährlicher weg die bühne
für die amtseinführung im januar wird
bereits aufgebaut bis dahin sind es noch
68 tage jetzt fußball norbert es wird
ernst für den nationale ja die beiden
letzten gruppenspiele in der nations
league am dienstag spanien morgen abend
dann die ukraine
bundestrainer löw setzt vorne auf sein
top sturmtrio gabri seine und werner und
hinten auf abwehrchef schüle das a team
ist wieder da auch abwehrchef niklas
lüder nach seiner corona quarantäne da
er zwei trainingstage in münchen bei
einer relativ hohen belastung nicht gut
überstanden hat und keine nachwirkungen
hatte da haben wir uns natürlich dann
auch am späten dienstagabend entschieden
dass bei ihnen nachnominieren den
gruppensieg rückt der bundestrainer
nicht in den vordergrund eins nach dem
anderen den sieg am samstag das ist der
einzige schritt denn im moment machen
will von heute auf morgen bis morgen
abend über spanien rede ich im moment
nicht timo werner spielt erstmals wieder
in leipzig nach seinem wechsel von hier
zum fc chelsea und nach zdf
informationen gibt es unter den
ukrainischen spielern vier positive
corona fälle
morgen früh soll das gesamte team
nochmals getestet und dann über die
austragung entschieden werden und das
spiel wenn es denn stattfindet was wir
alle hoffen bleibt für uns im zdf morgen
abend ab 20 uhr 15
trotz der korona bedingten spielabsagen
in dieser woche will die handball
bundesliga am spielplan festhalten einen
vorübergehenden shutdown wird es nicht
geben
die liga vertraut ihrem hygiene konzept
drei spiele an diesem wochenende sind
abgesagt grundsätzlich soll die
bundesliga aber weiterlaufen
das entschieden die klubvertreter und
die handball-bundesliga heute obwohl es
in der länderspielpause vier corona
fälle bei nationalspielern gab weitere
spieler die kontakt hatten und zwei
teams sind in quarantäne
damit die saison fortgesetzt werden kann
wir haben ja genau das hygiene konzept
auch für krisen momente geschaffen und
sieht ja auch genau schutzmaßnahmen vor
und genau die werden eingehalten und
gerade weil wir ein hygiene konzept
haben sind wir jetzt in der lage auch
weiter zu spielen
so soll auch die handball wm im januar
stattfinden können
das was du mir vielen dank das
wochenende bringt im süden sonne im
norden wolken und überall sehr milde
temperaturen die details hat gleich
katja honnefer um 10 begrüßt sie im
heute-journal claus kleber hier
übernimmt morgen petra kastl und wir
wünschen ihnen ein tolles wochenende und
alles gute auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
jeden abend meine damen und herren jetzt
am wochenende gibt es martins sommer
das gibt es ganz häufig mitte november
das ist nochmal fast sommerliche werte
gibt schon heute gab es 19 grad am
oberrhein
das klappt natürlich nur bei der
richtigen wetterlage dazu muss nämlich
die wärme aus südwesteuropa heran
getrieben werden jetzt aber kommen wir
erst mal dichtere wolken im westen an
und die hängen zusammen mit dem tief
quentin das tief roswitha hier westlich
von quentin wird den wetterumschwung
anfang nächster woche bringen heute
nacht ziehen erst mal dichtere wolken
über norddeutschland und da kann es auch
ein bisschen tröpfeln sonst ist es
locker bewölkt
es bildet sich auch mal nebel die
temperaturen sinken auf werte von 5 bis
0 grad zwischen der donau und dem
alpenrand sonst werden 11 bis 6 grad
erreicht und morgen steigen dann die
werte auf 10 grad in schleswig-holstein
bis 19 grad am oberrhein
denn zwischen dem oberrhein und dem
alpenrand scheint die sonne strahlt
sonst ist es locker bewölkt und im
norddeutschen tiefland eher trüb da
fällt auch ein bisschen regen bei
südwind und der südwind sorgt dafür dass
es am sonntag sehr mild wird am
oberrhein klettern die werte bis 20 grad
und es wird erst mal freundlich sein
aber von westen kommen dann die
regenwolken heran
das ist dann der wetterumschwung zur
neuen woche daran liegen die
temperaturen nur noch bei 8 bis 14 grad
schönen abend noch